This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. All parents have moments when their kids test their patience. Leanne Young is no exception. I often yell at my kids for things that they did by accident, like spilling a smoothie or leaving a cap off of a permanent marker and making black permanent stains all over the sofa. When this happens and the couch is covered in black splotches or their smoothie on the floor, the perpetrators inevitably offer this defense.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。所有父母都会遇到孩子考验他们耐心的时候。莉安·扬也不例外。我经常为孩子们不小心做的事对他们大吼大叫，比如洒了冰沙，或者把永久记号笔的笔盖忘在外面，在沙发上弄得到处都是黑色的永久污渍。每当这种事情发生，沙发上布满黑色的斑点，或者他们的冰沙洒在地板上时，肇事者们总是会不可避免地为自己辩解。
It was an accident. It's not my fault. I didn't mean to do it. I shouldn't say this but I tell them it doesn't matter that you didn't mean to do it. I shouldn't say this, but I tell them, it doesn't matter that you didn't mean to do it. What matters is that you won't do it again. Liane's reaction, while understandable, is deeply ironic. She's a psychologist who studies how we read other people's intentions. We need to think about other people's minds in order to figure out who our friends are, who to avoid, whom to punish,
这不是故意的。这不是我的错。我不是故意的。我不该这么说，但我告诉他们，你不是故意的这并不重要。我不该说这话，但我告诉他们，你不是故意的这并不重要。重要的是你不会再犯了。莉安的反应虽然可以理解，但却极其具有讽刺意味。她是一位心理学家，专门研究我们如何解读他人的意图。我们需要思考他人的想法，以便弄清楚谁是我们的朋友、该避开谁、该惩罚谁，
whether to punish. And we need to read people's intentions in any ordinary interaction, like having a conversation and figuring out what to say and how to respond. As we go through life, we are constantly making sense of people's actions by interpreting their intentions. Our ability to read what is happening in other people's minds is like an invisible compass guiding us through life. But sometimes, it leads us astray. We misread other people's intentions, especially when we're angry or hurt. In the last few weeks, in our Relationships 2.0 series, we've looked at the importance of human connection and how we can become better negotiators.
是否应该惩罚。在任何日常互动中，比如进行对话以及琢磨该说些什么、如何回应时，我们都需要解读人们的意图。在我们走过人生的过程中，我们不断地通过解读意图来理解人们的行为。我们解读他人内心想法的能力就像一个无形的指南针，指引着我们前行。但有时，它会把我们带入歧途。我们会误读他人的意图，尤其是当我们愤怒或受伤的时候。在过去的几周里，在我们的“人际关系2.0”系列中，我们探讨了人类连接的重要性以及我们如何成为更好的谈判者。
If you missed those episodes, do check them out. This week on Hidden Brain, how our powers of observation allow us to navigate our social worlds until they don't? We are constantly trying to read other people's minds. When we interact with friends, relatives and co-workers, we ask ourselves, what is going on in this other person's head? What does she want? What are his intentions? Our ability to read other minds involves an extraordinary feat of cognition.
如果你错过了那些单集，一定要去听听。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨：我们观察力如何帮助我们在社交世界中穿行，直到它失灵。我们一直在试图解读他人的内心。当我们与朋友、亲戚和同事互动时，我们会问自己：这个人的脑子里在想什么？她想要什么？他的意图是什么？我们解读他人内心想法的能力涉及一项非凡的认知壮举。
Yet, it mostly unfolds in our heads without us being aware of it. Minus this skill, the simplest of interactions would be mired in confusion and misunderstanding. Lian Yang is a psychologist and neuroscientist at Boston College. She has spent years studying this mental ability and the profound effects it has on our lives. Lian Yang, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much.
然而，这一切大多是在我们的脑海中展开的，而我们甚至没有意识到。如果没有这项技能，最简单的互动也会陷入混乱和误解之中。莉安·扬是波士顿学院的心理学家和神经科学家。她花费数年时间研究这种心理能力以及它对我们生活的深远影响。莉安·扬，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。
It's good to be here, Shankar. I want to start with a very simple example that shows how important it is for us to read what's happening in the minds of other people. In the 1993 movie, Mrs. Doubtfire, starring Robin Williams, the characters Daniel and Miranda have split up, and Daniel comes up with this unconventional way
很高兴来到这里，尚卡尔。我想从一个非常简单的例子开始，它展示了解读他人内心想法对我们来说有多么重要。在1993年由罗宾·威廉姆斯主演的电影《窈窕奶爸》中，丹尼尔和米兰达这两个角色分居了，丹尼尔想出了一个非传统的方法
to win Miranda back. He returns to the house in disguise as Mrs. Doubtfire, an elderly widow who seeks the role of nanny and housekeeper. Now, he quickly wins the trust of the family. Very soon, Miranda is asking Mrs. Doubtfire for life advice, including whether to go on a date with a man she's just met.
来重新赢得米兰达的心。他伪装成“道特菲尔太太”回到家中，这是一位年长的寡妇，想要谋求保姆和管家的职位。很快，他就赢得了这个家庭的信任。不久之后，米兰达开始向道特菲尔太太寻求生活建议，包括是否要和刚认识的男人约会。
Mrs. Doubtfire, may I ask you a question? Oh, certainly. How long after Mr. Doutfire passed away? Winston, did you feel any desire? Never. Never? Never again. Never again?
道特菲尔太太，我能问您一个问题吗？哦，当然可以。道特菲尔先生去世后过了多久，温斯顿，你才感觉到任何欲望？从不。从不？再也没有了。再也没有了？
Once the father of your children is out of the picture, the only solution is total and lifelong celibacy. Celibacy? Yes. So, Lian, if we lack the capacity to read what was happening inside the minds of Daniel and Miranda, how would that change how we understood this scene? Well, I think we wouldn't be able to appreciate the humor and the irony in that scene where Daniel is essentially, he knows what is going on with his wife and
一旦你孩子的父亲从你的生活中消失，唯一的解决办法就是彻底且终身的独身。独身？是的。那么，莉安，如果我们缺乏解读丹尼尔和米兰达内心想法的能力，这将如何改变我们对这一幕的理解呢？嗯，我想我们将无法体会那一幕中的幽默和讽刺，在那个场景中，丹尼尔基本上是，他很清楚自己的妻子发生了什么，
he is trying to get his wife to not date this other man. And of course, we know that the wife doesn't know Daniel's true identity as Daniel. She thinks that he is this housekeeper and we know that she doesn't know. And so there's this very sort of layered understanding that we need to have as the audience to find the scene funny. We can't find it funny without realizing that she doesn't know what he knows and who he is.
并且他正试图让他的妻子不要和这个别的男人约会。当然，我们知道妻子并不知道丹尼尔的真实身份就是丹尼尔。她以为他就是这个管家，而我们知道她并不知道。因此，作为观众，我们需要具备这种非常具有层次感的理解，才能觉得这个场景很有趣。如果我们没有意识到她并不知道他知道什么以及他是谁，我们就无法觉得它好笑。
Right, so we're able to read in some ways that he has an agenda here because he wants to keep his wife from dating other men. And we also understand that she doesn't know what's going on. But what's interesting to me, Liane, is that we entude all of this effortlessly. No one sits down as they're watching the movie and actually says to themselves, all right, this is what's going through his head, this is what's going through her head.
对，所以在某种程度上，我们能够看出他在这里有他的目的，因为他想阻止他的妻子和其他男人约会。我们也明白她并不知道发生了什么。但对我来说有趣的是，莉安，我们毫不费力地就能直觉到这一切。没有人会在看电影的时候坐下来对自己说，好吧，这就是他脑子里想的，这就是她脑子里想的。
It's the fact we're able to take it in so effortlessly that allows us to understand the scene. Yeah, so we're able to. And I remember watching this movie as a child who, of course, hadn't had the benefit of studying how theory of mind works in the brains of children and adults. And I still found it very funny. I knew exactly what was happening, who was misunderstanding, who knew what other people didn't know and so on in order to be able to enjoy the scene and really the entire movie. So you used a term just now, theory of mind.
正是因为我们能够如此毫不费力地吸收这些信息，才让我们能够理解这个场景。是的，所以我们能够。我记得我小时候看这部电影时，当然还没有研究过心理理论如何在儿童和成人的大脑中运作的好处。但我仍然觉得非常有趣。我确切地知道发生了什么，谁在误解，谁知道别人不知道的事情等等，以便能够享受这个场景，乃至整部电影。所以你刚才用了一个词，心理理论。
It's a term that you and other researchers have to describe our capacity to understand what is happening in the minds of other people. Can you explain what that term means to me? Yes. So I should say that term means to me? Yes, so I should say that many psychologists and neuroscientists use a number of different terms. Theory of mind is one of those terms
这是你和其他研究人员用来描述我们理解他人内心发生事情的能力的一个词。你能向我解释一下这个词的意思吗？可以的。所以我要说的是这个词对我的意义？是的，所以我应该说，
and that describes the theory that we all have, ordinary people have, about other people's minds. And what I mean by that is how we understand that other people have thoughts, beliefs, desires, and intentions, mental states in general. And so other terms that have been used for this general cognitive capacity include mental state reasoning, mentalizing, reasoning about intentions, and so on. And again, the fact that we do it so effortlessly, you know, many of us don't even realize that we're doing it.
许多心理学家和神经科学家使用了许多不同的术语。“心理理论”就是其中之一，它描述了我们所有人、普通人对他人内心世界的看法。我的意思是，我们如何理解其他人有思想、信念、欲望和意图，也就是一般的心理状态。因此，用于这种一般认知能力的其它术语还包括心智状态推理、心智化、关于意图的推理等等。同样，我们做这一切是如此毫不费力，你知道，我们中的许多人甚至没有意识到我们在这样做。
Many of us don't realize that if we're having a conversation and we were not able to intuit what was happening in someone else's mind, really difficult to have a conversation. Exactly, even as you and I are having this conversation, Shankar, I'm trying to figure out what it is that you wanna know and how to explain the term theory of mind in a way that will be accessible and so on.
我们中的许多人都没有意识到，如果我们正在交谈，而我们无法直觉到别人心里在发生什么，那交谈将会变得非常困难。没错，甚至当我和你进行这场对话时，尚卡尔，我也在试图弄清楚你想知道什么，以及如何以一种通俗易懂的方式来解释“心理理论”这个词，等等。
And sometimes we take different cues from people as we're having that conversation, whether they're nodding their heads, whether they're pausing, whether they look confused and so on. And so we take in all of that information to figure out what people are thinking and how they're responding to the information that we're giving them. Nearly all the world's greatest stories ask you to exercise theory of mind, to inhabit the minds of other people. Think of books such as Kazuo Ishiguro's The Remains of the Day, or TV shows such as Breaking
有时，在交谈时我们会从人们身上捕捉到不同的线索，比如他们是否在点头、是否在停顿、看起来是否感到困惑等等。因此，我们吸收所有这些信息来弄清楚人们在想什么，以及他们如何回应我们提供给的信息。世界上几乎所有最伟大的故事都要求你运用心理理论，去体会其他人的内心。想想卡夫罗·伊什古罗的小说《长日将尽》，或者像《绝命毒师》这样的电视剧，或者像《汉密尔顿》这样的音乐剧。我认为，当我们看电影、看电视节目、读书时，能够代入不同角色的视角是非常重要的，而且通常作为读者、作为观众，我们有一种不同寻常的、在某些情况下是全知的视角。我们可以看到场景以场景中的角色所无法看到的方式展开。因此，在某种程度上，我们以故事中角色所没有的方式理解了正在发生的事情。
Bad, or musicals like Hamilton. I think it's really important that we're able to take the perspective of different characters when we're watching movies, watching TV shows, reading books, and often as the reader, as the viewer, we have a sort of different, in some cases, omniscient perspective. We can see the scene unfolding in a way that characters within the scene cannot. And so on one level, we understand what's going on in a way that characters within the story do not.
而且我们不仅能够进入角色的内心，还能进入角色的心灵。所以我们知道他们的感受，以及他们如何以故事中其他角色可能没有的方式进行反应和回应。因此，心理学家们已经找到了不同的方法来测量这种能力，并测试它在幼儿身上是如何发展的。他们发现了什么，莉安？
And we also are able to not just get into the minds of characters, but get into the hearts of characters as well. So we know how they're feeling and how they're reacting and responding in ways that maybe other characters in the story don't. So psychologists have found different ways to measure this ability and to test how it develops in small children. What do they find, Leanne?
这是我们生来就有的技能，还是随着时间推移而发展的技能？这在学术界略有争议，但我认为学术界普遍认可的是，至少儿童对显性心理理论的能力——即能够对心理理论任务进行推理和口头表达答案——这种能力出现在三到五岁之间。心理学家能够对幼儿实施一系列心理理论任务，以弄清楚单个儿童究竟在什么时候能够将世界上的其他行动者视为
Is this a skill we are born with at birth or is it something that develops over time? This is a little bit controversial in the field, but I think what is generally recognized in the field is that at least children's capacity for explicit theory of mind, being able to reason and verbalize answers to theory of mind tasks, that ability emerges between the ages of three and five years. Psychologists are able to administer batteries of theory of mind tasks to young children to figure out when exactly it is that individual children are able to think about other agents in the world
拥有可能独立于现实情况的心智。其中一些测试创造了人工情境，其中一个角色比另一个角色了解更多。在《窈窕奶爸》中，丹尼尔理解他正在实施的诡计，而米兰达没有。这些测试评估儿童是否能够追踪不同角色心中的所有不同视角，例如一个人拥有真实信念，而另一个人拥有虚假信念。
as having minds that are maybe separate from the reality of a situation. Some of these tests create artificial situations where one character knows more than another. Daniel in Mrs. Doubtfire understands the subterfuge he is perpetrating. Miranda does not. The tests evaluate whether children can keep track of all the different perspectives in the minds of different characters, that one person has a belief that's true, for example, and another has a belief that's false.
所以，错误信念任务的一个例子就是萨莉-安任务，其中有两个木偶，萨莉和安。萨莉正在玩一个球，然后她把球拿走并放进了一个篮子里。她离开了房间，另一个木偶进来把球移到了另一个地方。然后当萨莉回到房间时，孩子们被问到：她认为她的球在哪里？萨莉看到安移动积木了吗？没有。
So one example of a false belief task would be the Sally Ann task in which you have two puppets, Sally and Ann. Sally is playing with a ball and then she takes the ball and puts it away in a basket. She leaves the room and another puppet comes in and moves the ball to a different location. And then children are asked when Sally comes back into the room, where does she think her ball is? Did Sally see Ann move the block? Uh-uh.
因为她当时在外面荡秋千。没错。没错。她没看到。所以当萨莉回来时，她会认为积木在哪里？嗯，在里面，但它不在那儿，它在那儿。所以她会认为它在里面。三岁的孩子往往会说她认为球在它真正所在的地方，
Because she was outside swinging. That's right. That's right. She didn't see. So when Sally comes back in, where will she think the block is? Um, in there, but it's not, it's in there. So she'll think it's in there. And three-year-old children will tend to say that she thinks the ball is where it really is,
尽管她本不应该知道安进来并移动了她的球，而较大的孩子，到了五岁时，就知道萨莉对球在哪里有一个错误的信念。对，所以一旦安移动了球，小孩子们就会推断或认为萨莉不知何故也凭直觉知道球已经被移动到新位置了，而较大的孩子们意识到，不，萨莉实际上并没有和安一样的心智，安知道的并不等同于萨莉知道的。萨莉只知道她自己所知道的，
even though she's not supposed to know that Anne came in and moved her ball, whereas older children, by the time children are five, they know that Sally has a false belief about where that ball is. Right, so once Anne moves the ball, small children deduce or believe that Sally must somehow intuitively also know that the ball has been moved to the new location, whereas older children realize, no, Sally in fact does not have the same mind as Ann, and what Ann knows is not what Sally knows. Sally knows only what she knows,
就她所知，球还在原来的位置，所以当她回到房间时，她会猜测球还在那里。你为什么认为她会这么想？我不知道，她能把它放在那儿吗？是的，完全正确。所以更小的孩子、三岁的孩子，并没有这样一个概念，即人们的头脑中可能会有背离现实世界、背离事物的信念。我们已经看过了关于心理理论如何运作的几个幽默的例子，
and as far as she knows, the ball is in the old location, so when she returns to the room, she's gonna guess that that's where it still is. Why do you think she'll think that? I don't know, can she put it there? Yes, that's exactly right. So younger children, through-old children, don't have a concept that people could have beliefs in their heads that depart from the reality of the world, the facts of the situation. So we've looked at a couple of humorous examples of how theory of mind
但我还是要再次强调我们这种能够直觉到他人内心正在发生事情的能力。这是一项我们一直在使用的技能。莉安，你能花一点时间谈谈如果我们缺乏这项技能会发生什么吗？在生活中，确实有人不具备这项技能吗？是的，这不是一种在所有人、所有情况下都表现得完全一致的能力。
operates, but I want to stress again this capacity we have to intuit what's happening in the minds of other people. This is a skill that we use all the time. Can you talk a moment, Leigh-Anne, about what would happen if we lack this skill? Are there people, in fact, who do not have this skill as they move through life? Yeah, this is in a uniform capacity
它可能取决于个人。它可能取决于语境，即使在健康、典型的群体中也是如此。我们还研究了特定的患者群体，包括患有特定脑损伤的患者。我们研究了被临床诊断为精神病态的监狱服刑人员，以及高功能自闭症成年人。因此，我们在不同人群中看到了各种各样的行为模式，特别是关于他们如何使用和如何
that we see the same in all people across all situations. It can be dependent on the individual. It can be dependent on the context, even in healthy, typical populations. We've also looked at specific patient populations as well, including patients with specific brain damage. We've looked at prison inmates with a clinical diagnosis of psychopathy, and we've looked at high functioning adults with autism. And so we've seen sort of a range of behavioral patterns across different populations of people in terms of how they use and how they
运用心理理论能力来做出道德判断。莉安和其他人发现，那些难以直觉他人内心想法的人在生活中会感到步履维艰。他们在人际交往中可能会显得笨拙。他们可能会在会议中无法看清局势。
deploy theory of mind capacities for moral judgments in particular. Liane and others have found that people who have a difficult time intuiting what is going on in the minds of other people find themselves hamstrung as they go through life. They can be awkward in interpersonal settings. They can fail to read the room in a meeting.
他们甚至可能表现出对他人同理心的减少。在没有意识到他人的心智与你不同、他们有着不同的意图、欲望和希望的情况下在这个世界上前行，就像在没有节奏感的情况下演奏音乐。你会发现自己总是与你的音乐同伴们合不上拍。我的意思是，我们都遇到过这样的情况：一个笑话冷场了，因为讲笑话的人无法恰当地评估现场的氛围，或者其他人知道什么、不知道什么等等。
They may even demonstrate reduced empathy for others. Moving through the world without an understanding that other minds are different than your own, that they have different intentions, desires, and hopes, this is like playing music without a sense of rhythm. You find yourself constantly out of sync with your fellow musicians. I mean, we've all been in a situation where a joke falls flat because the person who's telling the joke isn't able to appropriately assess the mood in the space or what other people know or don't know and so on.
所以这方面的情况肯定有很多。然后还有相反的情况，我们真的很佩服那些对别人的想法和感受有敏锐洞察力，并能够以此塑造对话或讨论的个人。你知道，我想起了心理学家E·托里·希金斯的工作，他做了一些研究，发现政客们非常擅长察言观色。
And so certainly there are many cases of that. And then there are sort of the opposite cases where we really admire individuals for having a keen sense of what other people are thinking and feeling and able to shape a conversation or discussion in that way. You know, I'm reminded of the work of the psychologist, E. Tory Higgins, who's done some work looking at politicians who are very skilled at reading a room.
他描述了一种被称为“听众调谐”的现象，在某种程度上，政客们（你知道的）改变他们所说的话，以便被房间里的人们更好地接受。他们在某种程度上操纵了（你知道的）房间里的人，但他们同时也受到房间里的人的操纵，以便他们所说的话与房间里的听众保持一致。有趣的是，所以心理理论不仅仅发生在人际层面上，我想它也可以发生在群体环境中，我们能够直觉到一个群体的人的感觉，或者他们对我们的感觉。
He describes this phenomenon called audience tuning, where in some ways the politicians are, you know, changing what they say in order to be best received by the people in the room. They're in some ways manipulating, you know, the people in the room, but they're also being manipulated by the people in the room so that what they say aligns with the audience in the room. And it's interesting, so theory of mind is not just, I suppose, on an interpersonal level. It can also happen at a group setting where we intuit how a group of people is feeling or feeling toward us.
是的，你说得对。因此，试图弄清楚心理理论在任何特定情况下是如何发挥作用的，可能会非常复杂。你知道，在我的实验室里，尤其是在Zoom上，如果你愿意的话，要看清局势会困难得多，要作为一个群体弄清楚人们的情况以及如何塑造这个空间会困难得多。莉安和其他研究人员试图理解物理大脑是如何产生这种超能力的。
Yeah, you're right. And so it can be very complicated trying to figure out how theory of mind plays out in any given situation. You know, in my lab, when I'm particularly on Zoom, it can be a lot harder to read the room, if you will, figure out, you know, as a group, how people are doing and how to shape that space. Lian and other researchers have tried to understand how the physical brain produces the superpower.
令人惊讶的是，他们发现大脑的一个特定区域起着至关重要的作用。他们甚至发现你可以暂时干扰这个大脑区域，并深刻改变人们思考和行事的方式。我们休息一下，马上回来。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。为了在我们的社交世界中航行，我们依靠心理学家所称的“心理理论”。这是我们猜测他人意图、欲望和动机的能力。当你的同事告诉你她很高兴今天是星期一时，你知道那是讽刺，因为你无意识地捕捉到了她话语背后的意图。
Surprisingly, they found a specific region of the brain plays a crucial role. They've even found you can temporarily disrupt this brain region and profoundly change the ways people think and act. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. To navigate our social worlds, we rely on something psychologists call theory of mind. It's our ability to guess the intentions, desires and motivations of other people. When your coworker tells you she's thrilled it's Monday, you know that's sarcasm because you unconsciously pick up the intention behind her words.
但尽管我们的社交天线如此惊人，它们有时也会犯错。我们可能会误解他人的意图。也许你的同事真的喜欢星期一。心理学家兼神经科学家莉安·扬研究我们的大脑如何解读意图——包括他人的意图和我们自己的意图，尤其是在涉及我们的道德判断时。莉安，你做过一些实验，测试志愿者对一个关于一个女人意外毒死她朋友的故事的反应。你能告诉我实验的设定并更详细地描述一下这个情景吗？
But as amazing as our social antennae can be, they can also sometimes make mistakes. We can misread other people's intentions. Maybe your co-worker really does like Mondays. Psychologist and neuroscientist Lian Yang studies how our brains read intention, both the intentions of others and of ourselves, especially when it comes to our moral judgments. Lian, you run experiments where you test how volunteers react to a story about a woman who accidentally poisoned her friend. Can you tell me the setup of the experiment and describe the scenario in more detail?
好的，没问题。所以我们通常会让我们的受试者阅读我们编写的故事，故事关于其他人正在执行对情境中的其他人产生影响的行动。所以在其中一个故事中，我们有一个名叫格蕾丝的人，她把一些粉末放进同事的咖啡里。在一个情境中，她以为粉末是糖，但粉末结果却是毒药，她最终毒死了她的朋友。所以这是由于错误信念而导致某人意外伤害另一个人的情境的一个版本。在故事的另一个版本中，格蕾丝把粉末放进同事的咖啡里。
Yes, absolutely. So we usually have our subjects read stories that we write about other people who are performing actions that have effects on other people in the scenario. So in one story, we have a person named Grace who puts some powder into a co-worker's coffee. And in one scenario, she thinks the powder is sugar, but the powder turns out to be poison, and she ends up poisoning her friend. So that's a version of the scenario in which someone causes harm to someone else by accident because of a false belief. In another version of the story, Grace puts powder into her co-worker's coffee.
她以为粉末是毒药，但结果却是糖。所以这是一种她有有害意图，但没有造成伤害的情况。因此，在这两种情况下，行为人的意图和行为人的行动结果之间存在冲突。所以我们可以向我们的志愿者参与者询问他们对行动者（执行行动的人）以及行动本身的道德判断，即这一行动是道德上允许的还是道德上禁止的。通过使用这些类型的情境和这些类型的道德判断量表，我们可以了解不同的人在多大程度上依赖关于意图的信息来做出他们的
She thinks the powder is poison, but it turns out to be sugar. So that's a situation in which she has a harmful intention, but no harm is done. So in these two cases, there is a conflict between the intention of the agent and the outcome of the agent's action. And so we can ask our volunteer participants for their moral judgments of both the person, the agent performing the action, and also the action itself, whether this action is morally permissible or morally forbidden. And using these kinds of scenarios and these kinds of moral judgment scales, we can get a sense for the extent to which different people rely on information about intentions to make their
道德判断。因此，举例来说，你和我可能会对意外毒死同事有多严重持有截然不同的观点。根据具体情况的不同，可能会出现这样一种情况：她绝对不可能知道有人把糖和毒药调换了，而且她怀揣着最好的意图。因此，在这些情况下，道德判断的个体差异有很大的灵活性。
moral judgments. So you and I, for instance, could have very different views about how bad it is to accidentally poison a coworker. And sort of depending on the circumstances, there could be a situation in which there's just no way she could have known maybe somebody swapped the sugar and the poison and she had the best of intentions. And so those are cases where there's a lot of flexibility for individual variation in moral judgments.
我们可以将同样的推理应用到造成伤害未遂的情况中。有些人可能更关注中立的结果，即根本没有发生任何坏事，而另其他人可能会更多地关注这个人刚刚试图毒死他们的同事，这非常非常糟糕。是的，当我听这些情境时，我会说那个没有伤害朋友的意图但意外造成伤害的人实际上是无辜的。但那个意图造成伤害却没有造成伤害的人实际上是
We can apply that same reasoning to the case of a failed attempt to cause harm too. Some people might focus more on the neutral outcome, the fact that nothing bad happened at all, whereas other folks might focus a lot more on the fact that this person just tried to poison their coworker and that's very, very bad. Yeah, as I was listening to those scenarios, I would have said that the person who didn't mean to harm her friend but accidentally caused harm is in fact innocent. But the person who didn't cause harm when she intended to cause harm was in fact
有罪的，这是一个谋杀未遂的行为。你有见地去研究人们不仅如何得出不同的结论，而且当他们得出这些不同的道德判断时他们的大脑是如何运作的。你能告诉我那些研究以及你的发现吗，莉安？所以我们现在已经使用脑成像技术进行了多项研究，以观察人们在对这些类型的情况做出道德判断时大脑是如何反应的。
culpable that this was an act of attempted murder. You had the insight to study not just how people reach different conclusions, but how their brains were operating as they reached these different moral judgments. Can you tell me about those studies and what you found, Liane? So we've run a number of studies now using brain imaging techniques to look at how people's brains are responding as they're making moral judgments of these kinds of cases.
所以在其中一项研究中，我们发现了一个被称为右侧颞顶联合区的大脑区域，它位于你右耳的正上方和后方，该区域处理关于人们意图的信息。我们发现，当个人在做出这些道德判断时，其右侧颞顶联合区的反应越强烈，他们在多大程度上就越是利用关于无辜意图的信息来放过因意外而造成伤害的人。因此，我们看到了该区域追踪意图信息的脑活动与人们对意外伤害做出的道德判断之间存在这种相关性。
And so what we found in one study was that a brain region called the right temporoprital junction, which is right above and behind your right ear, processes information about people's intentions. And what we found was that the more an individual's right temporoprital junction responds as they are making these moral judgments, the more they are using information about innocent intentions to let the person who caused harm by accident off the hook. And so we see this correlation between brain activity in this region that tracks intention information and the moral judgments that people are making of accidental harms.
所以你当然可以说，仅仅因为一个大脑区域显得活跃，你并不一定知道它实际上与你看到的产出和行为相连，但你已经又向前迈进了一步，实际测试了这个大脑区域是否确实与理解他人意图有关。告诉我你是怎么做到这一点的，莉安。
So you could of course say that merely because a brain region appears active, you don't necessarily know that it's actually connected to the outcome and behavior that you're seeing, but you've gone a step further to actually test whether this brain region is in fact implicated in understanding the intentions of others. Tell me how you've done this, Leigh-Anne.
除了使用脑成像（这有助于我们追踪人们在做出道德判断时大脑在做什么）之外，我们还使用了一种称为经颅磁刺激（简称TMS）的技术，来暂时中断这个特定大脑区域（右侧颞顶联合区）的活动，
In addition to using brain imaging, which helps us to track what brains are doing as people are making moral judgments, we've also used a technique called transcranial magnetic stimulation, or TMS, for short, to temporarily disrupt activity in this particular brain region, the right temporal pridal junction,
以观察它对人们所做出的道德判断有什么影响。因此，当我们暂时中断这个大脑区域的活动时，我们发现人们的道德判断在这些我们一直在讨论的情况中较少依赖关于意图的信息。举个例子，如果你正在读一个故事，讲的是某人试图毒死他们的朋友但未能成功，因为他们把物质误认为是毒药但实际上是糖，如果我中断了你右侧颞顶联合区的活动，与我不中断你右侧颞顶联合区活动相比，你更有可能说这更加可以接受。
to see what effect that has on the moral judgments that people make. And so when we temporarily disrupt activity in this brain region, we see that people's moral judgments rely less on information about intentions in these kinds of cases that we've been talking about. So to give you an example, if you are reading a story about somebody who tries to poison their friend but fails to do so because they mistook the substance for poison but it was in fact sugar, if I am disrupting activity in your right temporal parietal junction, you'll be more likely to say that that is more okay than if I didn't disrupt activity
这其实有点令人不安，不是吗？这种想法是：你扰乱了我大脑的一小部分，而我认为是自我核心的东西——我如何认为自己是一个道德的人——居然可以被神经化学的小小变化所改变。我想我们许多人都有一种直觉，这得到了心理学最近实证研究的证实，即我们如何思考道德情境或道德信念，对于我们
in your right temporal pridal junction. That is actually somewhat disturbing, isn't it? The idea that you disrupt a small portion of my brain and something that I think of as core to myself, how I think of myself as being a moral person can be altered by small changes in neurochemistry. I think a lot of us share the intuition that is confirmed by recent empirical work in psychology that how we think about moral situations or moral beliefs are really central to what we
所认为的身份认同至关重要。我们将我们的道德认同视为自我概念的核心。因此，认为干预措施——科学干预措施——可以改变我们的道德判断，在某种程度上是令人不安的。话虽如此，作为神经科学家，我们一直认为我们的道德判断在大脑中有其位置。因此，顺理成章的是，当你扰乱人们大脑中的活动时，你也会扰乱我们将要做出的各种判断，包括道德判断。而且有如此多的研究
consider to be our identity. We take our moral identity as central to our self-concept. And so to think that interventions, scientific interventions, can alter our moral judgments is in some ways upsetting. That said, as neuroscientists, we've assumed all along that our moral judgments have some place in the brain. And so it stands to reason that when you disrupt activity in people's brains, that you will be disrupting the kinds of judgments that we'll be making too, including moral judgments. And there is so much work
关于对行为的无意识影响。因此，一个人是否赶着去某个地方可以改变或影响他们停下来给无家可归的人钱的可能性。某个地方可以改变或影响他们停下来给无家可归的人钱的可能性。因此，我认为存在环境影响，不同文化的人在多大程度上依赖意图信息也存在文化差异。所以从很多方面来说，我不确定我是否会因为闻到新鲜饼干的香味会影响我的行为
on the unconscious influences on behavior. And so whether someone is in a rush to get somewhere can change or impact the likelihood of their stopping to give money to a homeless person. somewhere can change or impact the likelihood of their stopping to give money to a homeless person. And so I think that there are environmental influences, there are cultural differences in the degree to which people rely on intention information. And so in many ways, I'm not sure that I would be more upset by the fact that smelling fresh cookies is going to impact my behavior
或者你知道有人将经颅磁刺激应用于我的大脑会影响我的行为或决策而感到更加不安。我们的很多道德推理都取决于我们考虑他人意图的能力。当某人犯了错误但我们看到他们并非有意时，我们通常对他们不那么严厉。这就是为什么孩子们会说：“这不是故意的。”但正如莉安所指出的，许多因素可以改变我们如何以及是否愿意考虑做错事的意图。当某人在走廊里踩到你的脚时，你自动会假设他们不是故意的。你的脑海会倾向于一种无辜的解释。但其他情况则正好相反。它们
or you know somebody applying transcranial magnetic stimulation to my brain is going to impact my behavior or my decision-making. So much of our moral reasoning depends on our ability to consider the intentions of other people. When someone makes a mistake but we see they didn't mean to do it, we usually are less harsh with them. This is why kids say, it was an accident. But as Lian points out, a number of factors can change how and whether we are willing to consider the intentions of a wrongdoer. When someone steps on your toe in the hallway, you automatically assume they didn't mean to do it. Your mind gravitates to an innocent explanation. But other situations work the opposite way. They
让我们几乎不可能去思考结果背后的意图。考虑一下芝加哥这则令人不安的新闻报道。六点钟，一名下班的芝加哥警察现在被指控在西罗杰斯公园撞倒并撞死了一名骑自行车的九岁男孩。赫歇尔·温伯格在周三晚上被一辆在萨克拉门托街和蔡斯街交叉口、就在他家旁边的斑马线撞击他的皮卡车撞倒后死亡。
make it nearly impossible for us to think about the intentions behind an outcome. Consider this disturbing news story out of Chicago. Six o'clock an off-duty Chicago police officer now sighted with hitting and killing a nine-year-old boy riding his bike in West Rogers Park. Herschel Weinberger died Wednesday night after a pickup truck hit him in the crosswalk at Sacramento and Chase right by his house.
留在现场的司机正是那名下班的警察。他被指控……现在，当我听到这个消息时，我发现很难去思考这个警察是否存心造成任何伤害。一个九岁的小孩死了。司机的意图似乎无关紧要。当我听说——正如本案中实际发生的那样——这名警察只收到了
The driver who stayed at the scene was that off-duty police officer. He's been sighted with... Now, when I hear this, I find it really difficult to think about whether the police officer meant to do any harm. A nine-year-old child is dead. The intentions of the driver seem irrelevant. And when I hear, as actually happened in this case, that the police officer was given a
交通罚单而不是刑事指控时，我感到愤怒。但问题是，如果这名警察闯了停车标志，事情就到此为止了，我认为他应该受到刑事指控吗？那太荒谬了。因此，有着相同意图的相同行为促使我的大脑得出了截然不同的结论。这里存在一种可怕的张力：
traffic citation rather than a criminal charge, I feel outraged. But here's the thing, if the cop had run a stop sign and that was the end of it, do I think he should be criminally charged? That would be absurd. So the same actions with the same intentions caused my mind to reach for very different conclusions. There is this terrible tension
一方面没有人意图造成伤害，没有人意图杀死任何人，而另一方面这个九岁小男孩死了。再深入一步，你可以想象这样一种情况：他没有闯停车标志。也许他只是在开车，而孩子突然从某个地方冲了出来。我想我们仍然会有这样一种直觉：如果你促使了该事件的发生，如果你造成了那个糟糕的结果，那么在某种程度上，你对一件非常糟糕的事情负有因果责任，而这件事是你不知道
between the fact that nobody meant any harm, nobody meant to kill anyone, and the fact that this nine-year-old boy died. And to take it a step further, you could think of a case in which he hadn't run a stop sign. Maybe he was just driving and the child came out of nowhere. I think we would still have the intuition that if you caused that event to happen, if you caused that bad outcome, then there is a way in which you are causally responsible for something very bad that you didn't know
你会做出的，并且可能无法阻止。因此，正如你所指出的，如何处理那种情况真的很棘手。我认为不同的人对发生的事情、应该做些什么以及如何防止再次发生有不同的反应。还有一些情况，我们思考意图的能力被禁用了。如果我们听说某人知情与同胞乱伦，你可能不会停下来思考两个同胞是否都同意或者是否没有其他人受到影响。对禁忌的违反，这个
that you would be doing and maybe could not have prevented. And so it's really tricky to figure out how to handle that kind of case, as you point out. I think different people have different responses to what happened and what should be done and how to prevent that from happening again. There are other situations where our ability to think about intentions gets disabled. If we hear that someone has knowingly committed incest with a sibling, you might not stop to think about whether both siblings consented or that no one else was affected. The violation of the taboo, the
结果，才是唯一重要的事。而且通常在这些情况下，我们会淡化意图信息。你不知道并不重要，你做了这件事这个事实本身就足够糟糕了。所以，再次如我所提到的，这发生在与食物和性相关的违规行为中。在这些情况下，一旦你被玷污了，你几乎无能为力来再次变干净。而且你几乎说不出什么来为该行为辩解或减轻罪责，包括
outcome, is all that matters. And often in these cases we downplay intent information. It doesn't matter that you didn't know the fact that you did it is bad enough. And so that happens for, again, as I mentioned, violations related to food and sex. And those are cases in which once you are sort of defiled, there's very little that you can do to get clean again. And there's very little that you could say to sort of justify or mitigate the behavior including
你不知道或者这不是故意做的。莉安，我想花一点时间谈谈我们对事件的理解如何随着我们对这些事件背后意图的理解而改变？2001年9月11日，当第一架飞机撞击世界贸易中心双子塔时...2001年9月11日，当第一架飞机撞击世界贸易中心双子塔时，没有人知道发生了什么。事实上，许多新闻报道猜测，这可能某种程度上是一场意外。但当第二架飞机撞击时，它改变了人们对正在发生的事情的理解。第二架飞机清楚地表明这些袭击是蓄意为之的。
That you didn't know or that it wasn't done on purpose. I Want to talk a moment Leanne about how our understanding of events changes as our understanding of the intentions behind those events? Changes on September 11 2001 when the first plane hit the World Trade Center tower On September 11, 2001, when the first plane hit the World Trade Center tower, no one knew what was happening. Many news reports, in fact, speculated, it might've been some kind of accident. But when the second plane hit, it changed the way people understood what was happening. The second plane made it clear the attacks were intentional.
是的，绝对如此。所以，我们将一个事件解释为只是一场自然灾害、一次（你知道的）技术故障，还是一次协同计划的袭击，真的会影响我们对这些事件的反应。因此，当我们听到这样的事情时，我想（你知道的）首先我们会问自己，或者阅读新闻以找出发生了什么。然后我们想知道为什么以及是谁（如果相关的话）。所以我们以那种顺序提出这些类型的问题。正如你所说，我们对这些问题的回答确实有助于将事件理解为一场不幸，或者我们在试图弄清楚是谁干的、为什么以及我们可以做些什么来防止它在
Yeah, exactly. So whether we interpret an event as just a natural disaster or a, you know, technical malfunction or as a coordinated planned attack can really affect the way that we respond to those events. And so when we hear about something like that, I think, you know, first we ask ourselves or, or, you ourselves or read the news to find out what happened. And then we want to know why and who, if relevant. And so we ask those kinds of questions in that order. And as you say, our answers to those questions really help shape our understanding of an event as either misfortune or we are trying to figure out who did it and why and what we can do to prevent it from happening in
未来发生。所以你认为这就是为什么在某种程度上我们的大脑中首先具备这种能力的原因吗？我记得在9·11那天，我在《华盛顿邮报》的新闻编辑室工作，一旦我们知道两架飞机撞了世贸中心，第三架飞机撞了五角大楼，很明显我们受到了攻击，在那个时间点，（你知道的）它促使我们说，好吧，我们该怎么办？我们可能正遭受攻击吗？我们正面临某种危险吗？当然，如果我们对事件的解读不同，如果我们说，好吧，这是一起孤立的意外，它只是（你知道的）一架基本上失去控制并恰好飞进世界贸易中心大楼的飞机，我们对这起事件的反应将完全不同。我们会说，好吧，我们需要更好的飞行安全措施，更好的飞行员培训。因此，当我们解读这些事件背后的意图时，我们对事件的反应是非常不同的。我想知道，你认为这是否部分解释了为什么我们的大脑生来就具备这种解读意图的能力？因为当我们解读意图时，它告诉我们如何对世界做出反应。当然。我认为我们解读意图的能力
the future. So do you think this is why in some ways we have this capacity in our heads in the first place? I remember on 9-11 I was working in the newsroom of the Washington Post, and once we knew that two planes had hit the World Trade Center and a third plane had hit the Pentagon, it was clear that we were under attack, at which point, you know, it prompted us to say, okay, what should we do? Could we be under attack? Is there some danger that's facing us? And of course, if our reading of the events had been different, if we had said, all right, this was an isolated accident, it was just, you was just a plane that basically lost control and happened to fly into the World Trade Center
告诉我们如何评估我们周围的事件、如何理解它们、如何预测未来会发生什么以及如何在当下与人们互动。因此，这一切都取决于我们弄清楚意图以及将蓄意事件与意外事件区分开来的能力。这发生在我们阅读的许多新闻事件中。当我们读到一栋建筑倒塌时，我们会想（你知道的）发生了什么以及我们如何防止未来发生这种情况？同样，我们对这些问题的回答取决于这是否是故意发生的，
building, our response to the incident would be entirely different. We would say, okay, we need to have better flight security measures, better pilot training. So our responses to the events are very different as we read the intentions behind those events. And I'm wondering, do you think this might be partly why our brains come with this capacity to read intentions? Because as we read intentions, it tells us how to respond to the world. Absolutely. I think our ability to read intentions
是否有人造成了它，或者它例如是一场地震。因此，我认为你关于我们为什么拥有这种能力的提问是一个非常重要的问题。我认为作为心理学家，我们还没有对这个问题给出答案，部分原因在于心理理论能力之所以重要的原因有太多。我们需要思考他人的心智，以便弄清楚应该向谁学习、谁是特定领域的正确专家。我们需要了解人们的意图，以便弄清楚谁是我们的朋友、该避开谁、该惩罚谁、是否应该惩罚。
tells us how to evaluate the events around us, how to understand them, how to predict what's going to happen in the future, and how to interact with people in the present. And so all of that depends on our ability to figure out intentions and distinguish intentional events from accidental events. This happens in a lot of news events that we read. When we read about a building collapsing, we think, you know, what happened and how can we prevent that from happening in the future? And again, our answers to those questions depend on whether that happened on purpose,
在任何日常互动中，比如进行对话以及琢磨该说些什么、如何回应时，我们都需要解读人们的意图。当我们回来时，我们解读他人内心想法的能力可以是一种超能力，但这种超能力可能会让我们失望，有时会产生可怕的后果。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们解读他人内心想法的能力在某种程度上是一种心理超能力。它让我们能够毫不费力地在一个复杂的社交世界中航行
whether someone caused it or whether it was an earthquake, for instance. And so I think your question about why it is that we have this capacity is a really important one. And I think we don't have an answer to that question yet as psychologists, in part because there's so many reasons why that capacity for theory of mind could be important. We need to think about other people's minds in order to figure out whom to learn from, who's the right expert in a particular domain. We need to know about people's intentions to figure out who our friends are, who to avoid, whom to punish, whether to punish.
比如是有人造成的，还是地震造成的。所以我认为你关于我们为什么拥有这种能力的问题非常重要。我认为作为心理学家，我们目前还没有答案，部分原因在于，心理理论这种能力之所以重要，有太多的原因。我们需要揣摩别人的心思，以便弄清楚应该向谁学习，谁是特定领域的合适专家。我们需要了解别人的意图，以弄清楚谁是我们的朋友、该避开谁、该惩罚谁、是否应该惩罚。
And we need to read people's intentions in any ordinary interaction, like having a conversation and figuring out what to say and how to respond. When we come back, the ability we have to read other people's minds can be a superpower, but this superpower can fail us, sometimes with terrible consequences. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Our ability to read the minds of other people is something of a mental superpower. It allows us to effortlessly navigate a complex social world
我们需要在任何日常互动中解读别人的意图，比如进行对话以及弄清楚该说些什么、如何回应。稍后回来，我们解读他人心思的能力可以是一种超能力，但这种超能力可能会让我们失望，有时甚至会带来可怕的后果。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们解读他人内心的能力可以说是一种精神上的超能力。它让我们能够毫不费力地在复杂的社会世界中游刃有余。
and intuit what other people want and how they feel. This superpower helps us understand when bad things happen by accident, when they happen by design, and it allows us to tell friend from foe. Of course, the fact that our minds read so much into the intentions of others also makes the superpower ripe for exploitation by con artists, marketing gurus, and politicians. At Boston College, neuroscientist Leanne Young studies the psychology of theory of mind, our ability to think about the mental states of others Including their intentions in her lab. She and her colleagues explore the role of intention when it comes to making moral judgments
Leanne I want to talk about some ways in which our ability to read other people's intentions can sometimes go wrong And I want to start again with with television and and the arts And I want to start again with television and the arts. There's a very funny scene in the TV show Seinfeld. The character George has just gone on a date with a new love interest. They drive back to her apartment. They're sitting in the car outside, it's midnight. The air is crackling with sexual tension. And here's what happens next.
So thanks for dinner, it was great. We should do this again. Would you like to come upstairs for some coffee? Oh, no thanks. I can't drink coffee late at night. It keeps me up. So, um, okay. Okay. Good night.
Yeah, take. Okay. Good night. Yeah, take it easy. Leigh Ann, I'm not sure if you're a fan of Seinfeld, but what makes this clip funny is that George is actually not picking up on her intentions. Because it captures this phenomenon that we study in psychology called indirect speech, which allows for a misinterpretation of intentions. You know, because she's inviting George up for, quote, coffee, as opposed to asking him up more directly, it gives her plausible deniability. So if he declines the invitation,
she doesn't have to feel bad or offended or lose her pride. But on the other hand, it also leaves room for just misinterpretation and miscommunication, which is what happens a lot in real life. Such miscommunications can be trivial, but they can also sometimes have life and death consequences. A police officer might have to make a split-second decision
about whether a suspect is reaching into a pocket to grab a cell phone or to grab a gun. The officer has to read the other person's intentions in order to decide how to respond. And how he reads those intentions could be shaped by all manner of factors, including bias. Again, there is this question of what cues we are using to read people's intentions from their actions.
And what is really tricky about this problem is that we can't see into people's heads. We can't observe their thoughts or their feelings, we can only observe what people do and, you know, in this case, people's body movements reaching into a pocket, reaching into a glove compartment. And so that leaves room for misinterpretation and really awful consequences. misinterpretation and really awful consequences. So the fact that our ability to read intentions happens, you know, unconsciously, that most of us are not even aware that we are doing it, I'm wondering how much
of a role that plays in our misreading of other people's intentions, because presumably that also is happening unconsciously. Absolutely, and there are many cases in which we don't people's intentions because presumably that also is happening unconsciously. Absolutely. And there are many cases in which we don't realize that we are misreading people's intentions. In the Seinfeld clip, George realized shortly after the fact that he missed the boat on that opportunity because he didn't catch what the woman was doing. But there are many cases in which we don't catch our mistakes
and we're not able to fix them after the fact. I'm wondering in your own life, Leanne, have you noticed this happening of people failing to pick up on things, reading each other wrong? You've, I think, described during the pandemic, wearing a mask as you go into some stores or other social settings,
and wondering what people must think of you and what your intentions are. The pandemic is a really interesting case of intention reading and misunderstanding. So there have definitely been instances in which I've gone into a public indoor space wearing a mask and I wonder what people think about what I'm doing. Do people think that I'm unvaccinated
because I'm wearing a mask? And then I have to sort of stop and think about, well, what do I think when I see somebody wearing a mask indoors? Do I think that they're unvaccinated or do I think that they're being extra careful? Do I think that they're immunocompromised or they have young children who are unvaccinated and so on.
And so it becomes a really interesting exercise to think about how people are reading my intentions and then how to read other people's intentions and sort of backtrack from that exercise to the other. from that exercise to the other. Not only do we assume we can read the minds of other people, we often feel we can even read their character and intuit whether they are good people or bad people. It turns out we do this a lot in politics. We regularly misread the intentions behind the choices of our political opponents. We see them as malevolent. Here's a political attack ad
from the US presidential race in 1988. He vetoed the death penalty. His revolving door prison policy gave weekend furloughs to first degree murderers not eligible for parole. While out, many committed other crimes like kidnapping and rape, and many are still at large. Now, Michael Dukakis says he wants to do for America what he's done for Massachusetts. America can't afford that risk. So, what I hear in the ad, Leanne, is that Michael Dukakis was intentionally allowing criminals to go scot-free and commit more crimes. And, you know, the ad doesn't explicitly say that,
but I think it leads me to that conclusion. That's right. There are many cases where, because intentions are not black and white, because we can't see them, there's no clear evidence for intentions. This is a case where politicians are able to frame or reframe their opponents' intentions however they see fit to be able to shape other people's thoughts and feelings about others. There's this sort of ambiguity in this space. Politicians have the opportunity to be able to create different narratives,
particularly about people's intentions. I'm wondering how much of the daily partisan rancor that we hear, not just in the United States, but in other countries, is shaped by misreading the intentions of our opponents, that we're not just taking what they say and do at face value, but we're reading into it what we assume to be their intentions. A lot of times people do engage in this willful misunderstanding or misinterpretation of the minds of
people on the other side, but then in a lot of cases, I think this happens sort of automatically and unconsciously. We give people that we know and like the benefit of the doubt, and often those are the folks who are on our team or in our party, and we can interpret or understand those events very, very differently.
So if you imagine that somebody in your party is being accused of some transgression, you might start to seek alternative explanations for why they did what they were accused of doing. Whereas if you heard the same story of somebody committing a crime on the other side, then you might automatically take that story description at face value that they're guilty. You've conducted studies involving Democrats and Republicans or Israelis and Palestinians and obviously each of those groups is prone to misreading the intentions of their opponents. What kind of a study was this and what did you find, Leah?
We ran a series of studies in which we tested American Democrats and Republicans and also Palestinians and Israelis in the Middle East. And we gave them examples of acts of aggression in both of those cases and asked our participants to attribute motives. And what we found, which is maybe not so surprising but was very consistent across those different groups
of people, was that people were more likely to attribute acts of aggression performed by their own group to in-group love. People are just trying to defend their own values and their own people, whereas people would attribute those same acts of aggression performed by an out-group to out-group hatred. They're doing this to retaliate. They're doing this to attack us. And so it's very interesting that we see this asymmetry in how people are attributing
motives underlying the very same actions, depending on whether those acts are being performed by people on our side or people on the other side. This tendency to be selective in how we read intentions extends well beyond the realms of war and politics. Liane says we often interpret intentions in a way that confirms the stories we wish to tell about ourselves and others. I think we do that all the time and we do that in the ways that we interpret the intentions and actions of our friends as opposed to people we don't know or people that we know but don't like.
We give our friends the benefit of the doubt. We give ourselves the benefit of the doubt. We don't want to see ourselves as bad people. We don't want to see our friends as bad people. And so again, if you encounter a friend doing something morally ambiguous, you might make up an excuse for why they did that in order to read their behaviors as fitting with your narrative of being friends. And so it's very interesting that we see this asymmetry in how people are attributing motives underlying the very same actions in very different ways, depending on whether those acts are being presented as performed by people on our side or people on the other side.
You know, I'm reminded of a conversation we had some time ago with the linguist Deborah Tannen. She says it can be hard to recognize someone's intentions and so it's worth assuming that their intentions are good because it makes for smoother conversations. I think it's really useful for both relationships and also for ourselves to give others around us the benefit of the doubt. I think it makes for smoother social interactions and also for happier selves. What I've told my students is that if you have a bad interaction with someone, chances are they're not trying to offend you or insult you.
Maybe they're having a bad day, maybe they didn't get enough sleep. And I tell them to sort of think about our one-on-one interactions in the same context that if we have a bad conversation, it's probably because I am feeling bad that I yelled at a kid that morning and it has nothing to do with their paper or their project. And so again, we come back to this idea of giving people the benefit of the doubt and taking intentions
into consideration. I also think about times when I'm on the road and I get upset when other drivers cut me off and there's really nothing that I can do about it aside from give them the benefit of the doubt because I know that when I'm the one who's speeding or cutting other people off usually it's because you know my three-year-old in the backseat said she needs to go to the party or because we're rushing to an event and we're late and so to be able to extend that to other people, both strangers and the people that we interact with on a regular basis, I think just makes for
happier interactions all around. Isn't it really hard to do though, Leanne? I feel like, you know, even as I seek, you know, compassion and empathy from other people, it's hard for me to sort of give them the compassion and empathy that they seek. So there's a real paradox here. It's really hard. It's really hard to take that step back
and think about what are the situational stresses and influences that could be leading to other people's actions, whereas it's sometimes easier to see those external pressures on our own selves and lives and interactions. And so if we're able to pause in the midst of a tricky interaction and think about what that other person is trying to do or not trying to do, again, that will lead to much smoother, much more positive interactions and ultimately relationships.
Lianne Yang is a psychologist and neuroscientist at Boston College. Lianne, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. After the break, Your Questions Answered, our segment where we bring back recent guests of the show to answer listeners follow-up questions about their work. In this edition of Your Questions Answered, Fred Luskin responds to listeners' stories
of grudges and forgiveness. How can I tell whether what I'm doing, which is just I no longer interact with her, I don't speak to her anymore, whether that's truly a grudge or is it just me keeping myself safe? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Think about the last time someone really hurt you. Maybe it was a friend who betrayed your confidence.
A colleague who took credit for your work. A business partner who cheated you. How long did that hurt stay with you? How often did you turn it over in your mind, feeling a fresh wave of pain and anger, as though it happened just yesterday. The hurt we experience when someone breaks our trust is a natural emotional response,
but these emotions can start to eat at us if we hold on to them for too long. We recently discussed this with psychologist Fred Luskin, who studies forgiveness and grudges as the director of the Stanford University Forgiveness Project. If you missed our initial conversation with Fred, you can find it in this podcast feed. It's the episode titled, No Hard Feelings. Today, Fred returns to answer your questions about grudges and how we can come to terms with the wrongs done to us. Fred Luskin, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you.
Nice to see you again. One of the things that makes grudges psychologically interesting is that they involve a certain amount of mental storytelling. We weave our own personal narrative of a person and a wrong that they have done to us. You've said that grudges can be difficult to shake because we often start to combine different threads of various grievance stories and these stories start to weave together
and create a sort of meta-narrative. How does this happen, Fred? We're constantly trying to make meaning out of the world. And we have different levels of meaning-making. We have like small things, you know, that this person said something unkind to me. And then we have these meta narratives that say, you know, this isn't safe. And remember when your dad did what he did to you 20 years ago, which set you up upon a life which will not be safe, it makes it hard to just be with the experience and deal with the actual insult or not as it's happening or
cognitively or emotionally with the best strategies. You know I was talking recently with a memory researcher and she said something really interesting which is that our memories tend to produce whatever our current emotional states are. In other words, if we are happy, it tends to be easier to pull happy memories from our brain, and when we are sad, it's easier to pull sad memories from our brain.
And I'm wondering if the same thing in some ways happens with our grievances. So in other words, someone does something wrong to me and then all of a sudden it becomes so much easier for me to remember all the other times this person has also done something bad to me or said something unkind to me. If you're happy, then your brain and nervous system make available to you all the other lovely things in your life so that you get to think, now, wow, the last time I was happy, I went and hugged my partner. So should I do that again? From the painful side, look at how brilliant it is to give you access to other times that you suffered
and maybe to look through what were the strategies that I use that helped us. The problem is when it crowds out other memories then you actually lose access to thinking rather than gain access than thinking. But the original kind of substrata is really smart. I mean, you can think about it almost from an evolutionary standpoint, which is that if someone does something bad to me, if another animal does something bad to me, it's very useful to remember that this animal has harmed me.
And it might actually be useful to remember the other times this other person or this other animal has harmed me because that tells me now steer clear of this person, give them a wide berth. But what was very useful perhaps in our evolutionary history when it came to dealing with other animals and with predators might be less effective in the modern workplace for example where we're constantly interacting with colleagues and now we remember a small slight maybe it was an accidental
slight but that now compounds itself with all the other slights that we start to remember and now we form this meta narrative about how a colleague of ours doesn't like us or we don't get along with them. I'm going to add two things. It's not helpful, it's essential. That if there is pain, difficulty, hostility, mistreatment, you have to remember it. You have to try to process it and deal with it. That's not just optional. It's like essential.
The second piece, what I think you left out of the workplace, is the staggering amount of distraction that people have now. So not only are they in a workplace with maybe more interactions and more possible difficulties, their minds are frazzled even before they deal with anybody by emails, by texts, by relentless checking, by social media, by all of the just demands on their attention. So they come into work already with a higher level of arousal because they're so used to getting stimulated by this attention and you know like I'm at you all day long. So that has to be factored in there as well. So we've received a number of listener comments and questions from people who decided to sever a relationship with someone else.
Here's a question we received from a listener named Lydia. I have been living with what I imagine can be called a grudge towards my sister for the past almost eight years. How can I tell whether what I'm doing, which is just I no longer interact with her, I don't speak to her anymore. Whether that's truly a grudge, or is it just me keeping myself safe and my peace of mind? I can't imagine that all transgressions need to result in forgiveness and the ability to continue the relationship as though nothing happened. Or am I wrong about that? and the ability to continue the relationship as though nothing happened? Or am I wrong about that? So, what do you think, Fred?
I can see in some ways both sides of this equation. I might distance myself from someone because I'm holding a grudge, but I also could distance myself from someone because I've thought about this relationship and I don't want to continue it any longer. I'm going to continue it any longer. I'm going to add a third piece.
Often we move away from somebody because we can't handle the disturbance, suffering, stress that come up in us and we use distancing as a self-regulation strategy. So if my sister causes me every time I'm near her to feel anxious, angry, unsettled, sometimes if I don't have sufficient skill at going inward and rebalancing or whatever, I'll just keep them away to try to manage my own reactivity. That's incredibly common. On the polarities that the listener sent you, it's not so simple. One of the mistakes that she presented was you can forgive someone and choose not to have contact with them. It's not either or. She could look at her sister and say, whatever you did, I'm not holding anything towards you.
We're clean, but enough is enough. You go your way, I go mine, but there's no bitterness in me. There's just, you know, we tried this for 40 years, it didn't work for me, and have a lovely life for a while and thank you. So they're not mutually exclusive. What I would suggest is when you're dealing with your sister and like you want to see if you can rehearse even connecting with her. Like, are you able to create a bond or an outreach, even just in practice, if not that significant information that this may go really deep. Second, on the other side of it, if you get into a really quiet, clean, gentle space,
like you're lying on the beach in Hawaii and it's 92 degrees and you just got out of the water, if your insides still tell you that, no, this person is not safe for you, it's probably deeply in you that that's what you feel. But if it's just that every time you think of joining or connecting, you get anxious or upset, that may not be enough inner guidance to follow long term. You know, we like to think that when we forgive someone, our relationship with them is going to come out stronger on the other end. Unfortunately, that's not always the case.
Here's a question who has pretty strong narcissistic tendencies would never admit to have done anything wrong. This is my mom. She's since passed. And, you know, I am doing therapy, and I've done the radical acceptance and all that. But I imagine, you know, if she were alive and if I were to say, I forgive you, she would probably burst out laughing and say, you know, I haven't done anything wrong. And so I'm wondering technically how you actually forgive someone who
would never have admitted they did anything wrong. You know if if what I heard from her if the word narcissist tendencies is real and not just a becoming a cultural way of describing people that we don't like what they did. But if somebody has real narcissistic tendencies, you can't expect a full reciprocal relationship from them. You simply can't. So within that context, any forgiveness is just for your own peace of mind So that you will calm your brain down
You will open your heart back up Never with the thought that that's gonna improve them or have them see you as you are Because a real narcissist can't see you as they are. They see themselves. Again though, there's this confusion between reconciliation and forgiveness. You can forgive someone who's unrepentant simply because you don't want to carry that in you. You make no assumption that that will change them. Now, somebody who has weaker narcissistic tendencies and you forgive them and you show up, sometimes that does influence them to reduce their side of it, but there is no guarantee.
So in Sue's case, Fred, her mother is now dead. She may or may not have been a narcissist, but there's no way that she's going to be able to accept that she did something wrong because she's not with us anymore. But I think even there, the point that you're making still stands, which is from Sue's point of view, her forgiving her mother might be good for Sue, regardless of what her mother may have said or done. We can't know what will be good for someone else. And we can't know their perception
of what happened. We can only be as clear as possible about what our choices are and how our responses were. We've talked on many episodes of Hidden Brain about political divisions and how to engage with people in our lives who hold political beliefs that are different from our own. Here's a message we received from a listener named Ezra.
For years now, I have been holding a grudge with my family regarding their political stance, especially around queer and transgender rights. My parents have voted for Trump and I cannot tolerate the emotional cognitive dissonance of having parents who on one hand love me very much and on the other hand are literally voting to take my rights away as a US citizen.
I am stuck between wanting to forgive, wanting to protect myself, feeling fear and rage and love altogether. I would love some advice and help for how to move forward in a way that feels grounded, loving, protective, respectful. What do you think, Fred? What advice would you give to Ezra? What a lovely description of the poles of a mind, you know, that is trying to integrate the heart, but knows this is tough sledding. The real question is not should we forgive,
but what's our most skillful action and what's the best mindset for moving ahead. Like forgiveness is a pathway to the best mindset. It's not the mindset in and of itself. So when you're in a situation where you're vulnerable, like that listener just called in and legitimately afraid, that's not trivial and that can't be swept under the rug by saying, well, I forgive them. It's not that simple. But at the same time, we recognize that simply hating or demonizing whatever it is we think caused our vulnerability, after a while, will diminish our own ability to take skillful action. Because we're tired from our anger and our resentment
and clouds our judgment. So part of it is grieving and admitting our vulnerability and loss. Secondly, joining together with other people who have similar experiences so there's some strength in numbers. And then really focusing on within the legitimate experience of our life, what's the most skillful action? How do we behave in a way that will get us closer to what our real goals are and not just have us dominated by fear or resentment? That's the piece that forgiveness clears out. Say more about this idea when you say that the goal is to come up with
skillful action. How do we know what skillful action is for Ezra in this case? Well it can be a couple of things. One, that the goal or motivation you align with even when you're not upset or even when you're not meeting with other people in like shared outrage. But yeah, that's really what I believe in. Two, is it experimentally kind of verifiable? Like, I try this. Does it help?
If it doesn't help, do I admit that I was not doing the best thing and go back and try something else? Do I maybe ask for advice as to other people's experience? Do I read up about past skillful action? Is my mind open to problem solving or is it motivated by resentment and revenge? Those are very different motivations and they give us different minds to evaluate the outcome. I'm wondering whether any research has been done about the utility of actually asking the person who we feel has harmed us their advice on what we should do.
So in Ezra's case, for example, I'm wondering what if he went to his parents and said, here's what I'm feeling. I know that you love me very much I also feel like you have betrayed me. I'm struggling between my feelings of my love for you and my Admiration for you and my resentment for you. Help me figure out what I should do with these feelings You'd have to be incredibly Emotionally competent to say. And you would have to have really emotionally competent parents to hear that. But it is a phenomenal strategy. And you could extrapolate that strategy to so many interpersonal difficulties, just so many. You could
imagine how many intimate partners could bring that to each other. You know, you said this, it hurt me. Part of me wants to strike back at you. Part of me wants to understand you. But underneath what you said are some incredibly skillful means of I'm responsible for my emotional state. I need to put what I'm feeling into words to put what I'm feeling into words and I trust people enough to share my vulnerability with them. None of those are easy for people to access. Our guest is psychologist Fred Luskin joining us to answer listener questions about his work on grudges and forgiveness. More of those questions in a moment. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Your Questions Answered, our segment
in which we bring back past guests of the show to respond to listeners' follow-up thoughts and questions about their work. Today we are talking with Fred Luskin. He's a psychologist and director of the Stanford University Forgiveness Project. Fred is also the author of the books Forgive for Good, a proven prescription for health and happiness, and Forgive for Love, the missing ingredient for a healthy and lasting relationship. Let's turn again to listener questions. Our next one is from a listener named Laura, and it's a version of a question that we have received from a number of listeners. What if the person that you need to forgive is actually yourself? Could you apply the same concepts? What do you think, Fred? Is it
possible to essentially hold a grudge against yourself? The answer to that is yes. There's a couple of steps that, you know that people need to look at. One of them is to legitimately acknowledge what you have done. That there really is no self-forgiveness without some acknowledgement, some remorse. You know, if you look at truth and reconciliation in South Africa, it's just a general model. You know, there was a pretty strong public forum for, boy, did we do bad and this can't be hidden. So the first step is to whatever degree possible, admit it to yourself, if safe, admit it to anybody you've harmed and allow oneself to feel remorse.
对自己心怀怨恨有可能吗？答案是肯定的。你知道，人们需要经历几个步骤。其中之一就是正视并承认自己所做的事情。如果不去承认，不去忏悔，就真的没有真正的自我原谅。你看南非的真相与和解委员会，它就是一个通用的模型。当时有一个非常公开的论坛，表达了我们确实做了坏事，这是无法掩盖的。所以第一步是，在可能的范围内，向自己承认错误；如果安全的话，向任何你伤害过的人承认，并允许自己感到懊悔。
There is literature, you know, research on the value of a sincere apology, which is, I did it, my bad, hurt you, I make that link, I'm sorry, and if I can I won't do it again. It is hard for many of us to have the humility of a sincere apology. The last step is taken from the wisdom of the 12-step programs, which is whenever you can, make amends. Now if the person that you've harmed is just you, like you didn't harm anybody else, but you got drunk or you had a ridiculous sexual escapade that harmed your life, it's helpful to share with one or two trusted people as an offering, you do make a kind of inner me a copa, but the amends is you make sure it doesn't happen again. You go to therapy, you go to 12-step programs, you take classes in anger management, whatever it is, but you need to do something positive.
有相关的文献和研究探讨了真诚道歉的价值，那就是：我做了这事，是我的错，伤害了你，我把这两者联系起来，我很抱歉，如果可以的话，我不会再犯。对我们许多人来说，要保持真诚道歉的谦逊是很困难的。最后一步借鉴自12步戒酒项目的智慧，那就是只要有可能，就要做出弥补。现在，如果你伤害的人只有你自己，比如你没有伤害其他人，但你喝醉了，或者你有一段荒唐的性经历，损害了你的人生，那么与一两个值得信赖的人分享这作为一种补偿会很有帮助，你确实进行了某种内心的忏悔，但弥补的意思是确保这种事不再发生。你可以去看心理医生，参加12步项目，参加愤怒管理课程，无论是什么，你都需要做一些积极的事情。
When those preconditions are met, you have absolutely no need for negative self-talk or bad feelings. You have done the basic requirements of self-forgiveness. If you have to, you go see a therapist for a couple sessions, but you do not need at all that negative emotion once you've done those steps. In our initial conversation, Fred, we mostly focused on how we can let go of grudges against people who have wronged us. But we've all probably been in situations where we are the wrongdoer, where we have betrayed someone in our life.
当这些前提条件得到满足时，你就完全不需要进行消极的自我对话或产生糟糕的情绪了。你已经完成了自我原谅的基本要求。如果有必要，你可以去看几次心理医生，但一旦你完成了这些步骤，就完全不需要那些负面情绪了。弗雷德，在我们最初的对话中，我们主要关注的是如何放下对伤害过我们的人的怨恨。但我们可能都曾处于这样的境地：我们是做错事的人，我们背叛了生命中的某个人。
Here's a question we received about that from listener Buma. I want to know how you help a loved one get over or let go of their grudge or heart feelings or bitter feelings against you. Let's say you betrayed them, a terrible incident happened in their lives and you were not there for them. You realized it was a mistake, you regret it, you offered them an apology and later you have tried to be as best as you can for them and being supportive in their life but it looks like you know we both are still reeling from the aftermath of the betrayal I want to help this loved one
听众布马给我们发来了一个关于这方面的问题。我想知道如何帮助你所爱的人克服或放下对你怨恨、痛苦或苦涩的情感。假设你背叛了他们，他们的生活发生了一场可怕的事故，而你当时不在他们身边。你意识到这是一个错误，你对此感到后悔，你向他们道歉了，后来你尽你所能对他们好，在生活中支持他们，但看起来我们俩似乎都仍然深陷背叛的余波中，我想帮助这位挚爱之人，
and I want to help myself get better do you have advice? I mean that is a very tough situation when somebody feels genuine remorse, wants to make it right and is stymied. I have heard that multiple times. You know there's two things that come to my mind immediately. One is some degree of self-examination. What was it that led me to not be there when they needed me? Is there something character or logic in me? Um, was I frightened? Was I preoccupied? What was the flaw or weakness in me so that I can address it or I can show this person deep vulnerability and reflection when I talk to them. Not just that I'm sorry, but it caused me to recognize how hard something like this is, or wow, moment the depth of somebody's pain.
我也想让自己变得更好，你有什么建议吗？我的意思是，当一个人真心悔过、想要弥补却又处处受阻时，这是一个非常艰难的处境。我多次听说过这种情况。你知道，我脑海中立刻浮现出两件事。首先是进行某种程度的自我审视。是什么导致我在他们需要我的时候不在场？我身上是否存在某种性格或逻辑上的缺陷？嗯，我是害怕了吗？我是心神不定吗？我身上的缺陷或弱点是什么，以便我能够正视它，或者在我与这个人交谈时向他们展露我内心的脆弱与反思。不仅是说声对不起，还要让我认识到事情有多么艰难，或者说，深刻体会到别人痛苦的深度。
That would be one, you know, first of all, it helps her. But secondly, it creates a shared pain. The second thing is sometimes we can't turn back time. And there is a forgiveness element there that, you know, it's up to you and I respect as best I can how you deal with your suffering. The third piece is now that I have learned this about the dangers or even even if I didn't do anything deliberate even if it was just a bad confluence of events where absolutely nobody is at fault. One of the things that she can do is move ahead with a renewed attention to make sure that this never happens again so that her radar are more finely attuned to other people's pain and she can even use this
首先，这会有所帮助。其次，这创造了一种共同的痛苦。第二件事是，有时我们无法时光倒流。这里有一个原谅的要素，你知道，这取决于你，我尽我所能尊重你如何处理你的痛苦。第三部分是，既然我已经从中学到了危险的教训——甚至即使我没有做任何故意的行为，即使这只是绝对没有人该负责的糟糕事件的交汇——她能做的一件事就是带着全新的注意力继续前行，确保这种情况永远不会发生，这样她的雷达就能对其他人的痛苦更加敏感，她甚至可以利用这一点
as a teaching to tell other people never, you know, never underestimate when people are suffering, how vulnerable or how reactive they might be. So she can use her loss to help others. That's sometimes the best we can do. We received an interesting question from listener Richard. He wanted to know about the factors that might affect our ability to forgive someone. Here he is. Do you think someone having more positive emotional states, like the joy of their first child, may increase their likelihood of being more able and willing to forgive? I mean, if you ask me about the factors that influence the ability to forgive. Research has picked up a few, not that many.
作为一个教训去告诉其他人，永远不要低估当人们遭受痛苦时，他们可能会有多脆弱或多具有反应性。因此，她可以利用自己的损失来帮助他人。这有时是我们能做到的最好结果。我们收到了听众理查德的一个有趣问题。他想了解可能影响我们原谅他人能力的因素。他在信中问道：你认为一个人拥有更多积极的情绪状态（比如喜得第一个孩子的喜悦）是否会增加他们更有能力和更愿意原谅的可能性？我的意思是，如果你问我哪些因素会影响原谅的能力，研究已经发现了一些，但其实并不多。
One of them is gratitude, and it may be a surprise to you, but people who see the good in their lives are more capable of letting go of the bad. And that is a reasonably robust finding that, you know, if you wake up in the morning and it's a beautiful day out and you're delighted that you had breakfast and you look at a picture of your kid and you go, I got a good life, then when somebody calls you and is rude, you're going to be more likely to hold it better. Now, let me add one or two other things to that. A home where you were raised, where forgiveness is modeled, is more likely to imprint it on your brain than not. Did you see your parents forgive each other? Did you see your parents forgive you?
其中之一就是感恩，这可能会让你感到惊讶，但那些能看到生活中美好一面的人更有能力放下糟糕的事。这是一个相当稳健的发现，你知道，如果你早上醒来，外面天气晴朗，你为能吃上早餐感到高兴，看着你孩子的照片，心想我过着好日子，那么当有人打电话对你无礼时，你更有可能以更好的心态去面对它。现在，让我对此补充一两点。一个在你成长过程中将原谅作为行为榜样的家庭，更有可能将这一点铭刻在你的大脑中。你见过你的父母互相原谅吗？你见过你的父母原谅你吗？
That is a huge modeling that even can be pre-verbal, you know? Like, oh my gosh, I saw this. Second, our nervous systems have something to do with our ability to forgive. There's a quality of human nervous system arousal where people are called hot reactors. They just, you know, you've met them. They get aroused very quickly. Those people struggle like crazy to forgive, because the adrenaline just comes so quickly and so strongly and pulsates into anger that that is a real challenge.
这是一个巨大的榜样作用，甚至可以在有语言能力之前就产生影响，你知道吗？比如，天哪，我看到了这一幕。其次，我们的神经系统与我们原谅的能力有关。人类神经系统唤醒有一种特质，即人们被称为“易激动者”。他们只是，你知道的，你见过这样的人。他们被唤醒的速度非常快。这些人极其艰难地去原谅，因为肾上腺素来得如此之快、如此强烈，并转化为愤怒，这真的是一个巨大的挑战。
The last thing that I will say is it also depends on the amount of practice you put in. You know, if you practice just normally when you're cut off in traffic, when somebody cuts in front of you in the supermarket line, when the airplane is late and you're going to miss your connecting flight, you're practicing what you might need a year down the road when somebody doesn't behave right. Hmm. I think one interesting theme that's come up
我要说的最后一件事是，这也取决于你投入练习的程度。你知道，如果在日常生活中，当你在交通中被加塞、在超市排队时有人插队、航班延误导致你赶不上转机时，你都在练习，那么当一年后某个人行为不端时，你可能就会用到这些练习。嗯。我认为出现的一个有趣主题是
in many of these questions and also came up in our initial conversation, Fred, is that I think when people think about grudges, they sometimes imagine themselves to be in the position of judges. They're asking themselves, I'm a judge, here are the facts before me, do these facts justify forgiveness?
在许多这些问题中，也在我们最初的对话中出现过，弗雷德，那就是我认为当人们考虑怨恨时，他们有时会把自己想象成法官的位置。他们在问自己：我是一个法官，我面前有这些事实，这些事实是否证明原谅是合理的？
Should I hold on to the grudge? Should I grant forgiveness? Should I not grant forgiveness? And that is one way of thinking about it. But I think the point that you're making is that a judge is making a decision that really is in the public good. They're deciding, should this person be sentenced? Should this person be, you know be let free, and you're
我应该继续抱有怨恨吗？我应该给予原谅吗？我不应该给予原谅吗？这是一种思考方式。但我认为你所指出的一点是，法官做出的决定实际上是为了公共利益。他们在决定，这个人是否应该被判刑？这个人是否应该被释放，你知道的，
trying to make a judgment that's in the public good. When it comes to the forgiveness that you're talking about, Fred, you're really talking about what's in people's own good. And you're basically saying, is it in my interest to actually let this go, regardless of whether it's in the other person's interest or anyone else's interest? I'm going to add two things to that. One, there's also the statute of limitations, which most people forget about. Even if they're bringing an argument before the judge,
你试图做出符合公共利益的判断。谈到你所说的原谅时，弗雷德，你实际上是在谈论对人们自身有益的事情。你基本上是在说，无论对对方或其他人是否有益，放手对我来说是否符合我的利益？我要对此补充两点。第一，还有诉讼时效，这是大多数人会忘记的。即使他们把争端带到法官面前，
most cases have five, seven years statute of limitations. And so that's the water dampening on that analogy, even though it's true. Secondly, forgiveness is not just for the self, but it's for the current important relationships in one's life that one wants to maintain and grow. And again, let's just use the judge analogy. So let's say that somebody does something that's wrong. There's nothing wrong with imposing a one-week sentence on them. But then you also wanna be merciful and that's missing often in the judge analogy. Sometimes you let people out for good behavior.
大多数案件都有五到七年的诉讼时效。因此，这给那种类比泼了一盆冷水，尽管它是事实。第二，原谅不仅是为了自己，也是为了生活中当前想要维护和发展的重要关系。再次，让我们用审判法官的类比。假设某人做错了事。对他们处以一周的监禁并没有什么不对。但同时你也希望表现出仁慈，而这一点在法官的类比中经常缺失。有时你会因为良好的表现而释放犯人。
Sometimes you commute their sentence. So we're looking at a complex life, and we want to be careful not to lose the complex life on our over-fixation with a negative experience. Fred Luskin is a psychologist and director of the Stanford University Forgiveness Project. He is the author of Forgive for Good, a proven prescription for health and happiness, and Forgive for Love, the missing ingredient for a healthy and lasting relationship. Fred Luskin, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. I thank you very much. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. We had voice acting in today's episode from Clara and Rose Dubois and Scarlett McNally.
有时你会对他们的刑罚进行减刑。因此，我们面对的是一个复杂的生活，我们必须小心，不要因为对消极经历的过度执着而迷失了复杂的生活。弗雷德·卢斯金是斯坦福大学原谅项目的心理学家和主任。他是《为了善意而原谅：健康与幸福的秘方》和《为了爱而原谅：维持健康持久关系的缺失要素》的作者。弗雷德·卢斯金，非常感谢你今天来到《隐形大脑》。非常感谢。我是《隐形大脑》的执行主编。今天节目的配音演员有克拉拉·杜布瓦、罗斯·杜布瓦和斯卡利特·麦克纳利。
We end today with a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by Discover. In 2022, David Jefferson's wife Jill was diagnosed with cancer. Jill didn't have many close friends, but one of her former co-workers, a woman named Nicole Kyle, started coming by to try and cheer her up. Soon, Nicole became a consistent comfort to the couple. So in 2024, it didn't surprise David when Nicole offered to help him get Jill home after a hospital stay. What did surprise him was the lengths she went to once they got Jill home. David recorded his story in a park where he and Jill hoped to one day hike together, so you'll hear some wind in the background.
我们今天以来自我们姐妹播客《我无名的英雄》的一个故事结束。这个《我无名的英雄》片段由 Discover 赞助。2022年，大卫·杰斐逊的妻子吉尔被诊断出患有癌症。吉尔没有很多亲密的朋友，但她的一位前同事、一位名叫妮可·凯尔的女士开始经常来看望她，试图让她振作起来。不久，妮可成了这对夫妇持续的慰藉。因此，在2024年，当妮可主动提出帮大卫在吉尔住院后接她回家时，大卫一点也不感到惊讶。真正让他惊讶的是，把吉尔接回家后，妮可付出了多大的努力。大卫在一个公园里录下了他的故事，他和吉尔曾希望有一天能一起去那里远足，所以你会听到背景里有一些风声。
Nicole and I got Jill home. It was during a winter snowstorm. The pipes had frozen in the house, but we got them thawed out. Nicole and I gave Jill a shower and put her to bed. Some hours later, Nicole showed up with a bag. Show me which room you want me to sleep in, and I'll stay until the end with Jill. Nicole, in a very unselfish way, took care of the laundry, food, house cleaning. She invited her friends to bring over food along with some of the food my friends were bringing. Nicole would get up in the middle of the night with me and help roll Jill over and
妮可和我把吉尔接回家。那是在一场冬季风暴期间。屋里的水管冻住了，但我们把它们解冻了。妮可和我帮吉尔洗了个澡，并把她安顿在床上。几个小时后，妮可提着一个包出现了。告诉我你想让我睡哪个房间，我会留下来陪吉尔直到最后。妮可极其无私地包揽了洗衣服、做饭、打扫房屋的活。她邀请她的朋友们带食物过来，还带上了我朋友们带来的一些食物。妮可半夜会和我一起起床，帮吉尔翻身，并
attend to her private needs as only another woman could. Nicole was a steady presence. She never panicked. She always had a smile and willing to do whatever what was next. Nicole helped me see Jill to the end of her life, which was February 3rd, 2024. for. Nicole was an angel in the time of need and I'll forever be in her debt. This situation is my hero for life. Listener David Jefferson, Jill and David were together for 36 years. This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by Discover. Discover believes everyone deserves to feel special and celebrates those who exhibit the
照顾她只有另一个女人才能照顾的个人隐私需求。妮可是一个沉稳的存在。她从未惊慌失措。她总是带着微笑，随时准备去做接下来需要做的事情。妮可帮我陪伴吉尔走完她生命的最后一段路，那是2024年2月3日。妮可是在我们需要时出现的天使，我将永远欠她情。这种情况就是我一生的英雄。听众大卫·杰斐逊，吉尔和大卫在一起36年了。《我无名的英雄》这一片段由 Discover 赞助。Discover 相信每个人都值得感到自己很特别，并赞颂那些在他们的社区中展现出这种
spirit in their communities. I'm a long-standing card member myself. Learn more at discover.com slash credit card. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
精神的人。我自己也是一个长期持卡人。请访问 discover.com/creditcard 了解更多信息。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。